like connection with someone in a week
yeah i feel like i need to have that
conversation with you can you open up
exactly because are you able to open up
because a lot of men they get taught
from their mothers and family to not be
emotional to not talk about their
emotions to be a man to be strong you
know all of that so that's why i feel
like a lot of men also have problems
communicating their feelings because
they're not used to it
how long do you guys think that you
should be seeing a girl before you like
start to open up emotionally i think i
should do it as little as possible to be
honest because because it's bad advice
like you know i'm telling you like i
think you guys come at it with like a
good a good heart
but like
you're chemically less attracted to men
that are vulnerable
because like
and it's not it's not a nice reality but
this is this is how i know it every time
i ask girls have you dated an [ __ ]
they always say yes
they always say yes
that a second because you said like why
would you keep on sleeping with that
person i think for a couple weeks you
still have that hope that he might open
up someday but you end up leaving you do
but that's the reason you're not in a
relationship with that [ __ ] you're
just dating him well did he want to be
in a relationship the [ __ ]
probably not no comment yeah that's
that's what i'm saying but it's always
really good
and this is this is what i'm saying like
like in the reason the reason there's
like biological reasons that we feel the
way we feel and we can't just undo them
so the reason is because the same traits
that make the guy the hero also make him
the villain
so like like the guy that's the
protector provider like he he he has to
be you know aggressive on some level he
has to be able able to protect you and
emotionally in control you don't see
superman crying like
like in a movie you see hulk when he
like just goes all the way back to human
just for his girl
not necessarily crying them crying
so what would you say um
about i was just fictional about
leonidas to his queen in 300.
to her for sort of approval before his
next action before kicking the messenger
down the pit i mean i think you can
always find exceptions to the rule but
that doesn't make it the rule fair
enough like just because you can name
one example doesn't it like
and it's just like i just think we
confuse men and it makes them more like
feminine
and it's we're not attracted to it it's
not fun like i don't enjoy being
attracted to [ __ ] but i i like
i don't i don't enjoy it but like you
can't
admit you can't deny that it's there you
know what i mean
for me like being emotionally available
as a guy means also like
or specifically means you can
communicate with me it's not just about
like crying or you know breaking down or
anything like that it's just can you
tell me how you're feeling and i'm not
talking about like oh i'm so sad i mean
like
openly communicate with me what's going
right what's going wrong like just talk
to me yeah because a lot of guys when
you ask them like what's going on
they're like i'm good i'm good yes
what does what does i'm good means it's
exactly the same it's exactly the same
as i'm fine when you're not fine oh but
guys do that too yeah no that's what
saying that's what i'm saying
i'm good it's exactly the same as when
you go say i'm fine when you don't when
you're not actually fine that's
basically what it is but we we as guys
just don't like the better we say we're
fine yeah and then we come back and
we're like okay this is what's actually
going on you guys never come back we'll
ask you 10 times like what's going on
and then you'll feel like we're
pestering you exactly
you kind of have to drag them yeah
but that's that's why but that's why
like like she said that like yo you're
like not more attracted to the arseholes
in it because like if we start opening
up like maybe not to you or whatever
like you're maybe like one in a million
but like
if we start opening up to you like after
we say like oh i'm good and i come back
and i tell you what's actually happening
you'll lose respect for me you'll lose
that's
i've been in a relationship where a guy
told me everything that was bothering
him and i was going nuts
like i don't i don't want to hear every
single problem you have like you you're
not you're their therapist
like
and and this is but we have to be yours
as guys we have to stop no no no that's
a double that's the double because
listen you don't want to be our
therapist no no no you don't want to be
you don't want to be our therapist but
we we
have been you know you don't want to be
our therapist here but
we as guys have been but like not even
qualified to do but with your therapist
because when when you talk we listen we
listen good
to every little thing
what's really rude to me today
but i'm not gonna lie i feel like women
we don't tell
the guys everything either
like we don't tell them everything so i
feel like there has to be a balance
like i want to know about your life i
want to know what's going on and you do
the same but like there's the
communication part of it
just be open but you know don't tell me
everything
but do you see how confusing that is for
guys because you're like tell me
something but don't tell me everything
like
where is the line where is your life
like where's your guys's line
just tell me like tell me about the day
cool i woke up went to work come back is
that like is that the line is that
roughly where the line is
because that's what it feels like it's
like say something happened and it made
you feel some type of way that's what i
want to know because that's what is has
stuck with you throughout the day
oh i woke up i brushed my teeth i knew
that no but a lot of guys a lot of guys
growing up not being not knowing how to
communicate their emotions so when
they're in when they're adults in their
relationships they don't even know where
to start so if somebody i'm literally
that guy how's your day there's okay
like
do you know what i mean i'm cool how are
you i'm cool just because i won't even
know where to start if i'm to express
whatever it is i'm going through do you
know what i'm trying to say i feel like
from their own experience as well
when they have
like opened up or
like told them about the whole day or
whatever yeah it hasn't worked for them
yeah what's worked for them is like yeah
nothing i'm cool i'm good like that's
worked for them so yeah
yeah but wouldn't you want like a person
that you're able to actually talk to how
you feel yeah family members
other guys but like in a woman
no we don't we don't
well i just think like when you're when
you're asking guys to do that you're
asking them to be more feminine
inerrantly and like in the long run
you're not going to be attracted to that
i think i think you guys can relate to
that but if a guy if i love someone or i
care about someone what's bothering them
is bothering me
so if they're in a bad mood it's going
to affect me either way so i want to
know what it is so we can figure it out
and that's when
i'm sorry it's [ __ ] up because men
don't open up and then we're just
sitting there like
in a bad mood bad energy bad vibes
well i need you to be vulnerable i you
should tell me what's going on because
it's affecting me now as well and us
as a team
yeah but like you know what yeah i found
something else to flip it on you like
you know when you're you know when
you're the one that's upset but then
they
flip on you like why she gets upset with
you for being upset with yeah like
like what
how does that work
like like dude they would be like two
guys baby what's wrong nah i'm good in
it cool so they walk away they don't
fight they don't come back yes they come
back why are you always upset like they
come here
i swear like hold on that's the thing
because if we ask you what's going on
and you're like i'm fine i'm good
whatever that's why we get annoyed
because yeah exactly
but i think the real problem is
initially the guy's not in control of
his emotions
like i don't think it's the i think if
he was just in control of his emotions
to start and if he like and if he can
give you one specific thing to like like
work on that's one thing but it's when
the guys being all emotional and like
having a hissy fit and you're like what
the
is there an issue